[Musique]
bonjour pas un journal télévisé depuis
quelques semaines dans lequel on entend
parler de l'affaire clear stream mais
clear stream c'est quoi une lessiveuse
mystérieuse d'argent sal la clé de bien
des affaires de narcotrafic de trafic
d'armes et ou de mondialisation et de
licenciement notre invité aujourd'hui
est Denis Robert journaliste écrivain
artiste auteur il y a 10 ans d'une
enquête sur Clearstream Clearstream
c'est une chambre de compensation
financière basée au Luxembourg qui était
alors inconnue du grand public et dont
il dénoncer les agissements trouble
aujourd'hui tout le monde en France
connaît Clearstream c'est devenu
évidemment synonyme de Scand d'État 10
ans de bataille judiciaire 60 procès des
centaines d'huissers à votre porte de
solides inimitiés dans le monde
politique tout de même il en reste
également parmi vos nos confrères le
milieu de la presse et puis un éclair et
puis la nuit après 10 an voilà le 3
février 2011 c'est encore tout frais
tout récent la Cour de cassation vous
plancheéfinitivement et reconnaî dans
votre travail votre travail alors de
journalistes et d'enquêteurs
[Musique]
il y a internet quoi voilà ils peuvent
rien contre internet bah pas encore ils
peuvent rien sur intern non mais ils
pourront rien ils peuvent faire toutes
les lois qu'ils veulent je ve dire on
les emmerde quoi ils y arriveront pas
moi quand j'ai vu François Holland au
Bourger s'attaquer à la finance enfin et
cetera je trouvais ça pas mal mais je
sentais le gros coup de bluff en plus
c'est là-dessus qui gagne beaucoup les
élection parce qu'en face il avait un
Sarkozy sur l'histoire des banques il
était minable Hollande il en a rien à
[__] de la question des paradis
fiscaux c'est du discours c'était une
manière de de d'être au pouvoir sils
avaient vraiment une volonté politique
forte de lutter contre les paradis
fiscaux ils avaient ils ont toute
l'attitude pour le faire ben d'un point
de vue économique c'est une catastrophe
au niveau de la presse papier ça c'est
évident les ventes du poids ont baissé
de 16 % dernier trimestre celle de l'Obs
ont baissé de 14 et L'Express qui a fait
uneance a baissé de 10 libération est en
situation catastrophique est-ce que le
fait que les journalistes ne présentent
pas les chiffres correctement ou d'une
façon enjolée ou enjoleuse euh induit
une forfaiture du journaliste ou un
défaut d'information mais bien sûr enfin
votre question contient la réponse quoi
la presse financière est sans doute la
presse la plus inféodée et qui soit au
aux banques et au et au groupes
financiers le journalisme financier je
vais peut-être être comment dire être
lapidaire dans mon propos mais n'existe
pas on voit bien que derrière il y a des
groupes de pression des groupes de
presse et cetera et que on est d'une
manière générale bombardé d'indices de
chiffres de Bours et tout qui sont
complètement falsifiés il y a un espèce
de grand mensonge autour de tout ça et
je crois pas au complot je crois pas à
tout ça mais je je sais très bien que
ces journaux sont payés par par Arnaud
par Pino par et par par les banques et
qu'il y a des annonceurs et qu'il y a
tout ça et que et qu'on peut pas
déplaire quoi et je l'ai vu avec clam
c'était le SOMUM vous vous êtes bombardé
de procès et infin même si vous gagnez
vous vous vous vous perdez quoi les
éditeurs de presse ou les journaliste
les on tellement peur maintenant des
même plus de perdre des procès mais ils
ont peur des procès parce que les
procèdures ch évidemment il y a une
autocensure et il y a une censure et ça
c'est dramatique l'ffire kusac pour
parler d'elle a montré que que quand tu
as une volonté journalistique forte
tuarve à à renverser des des pouvoirs on
voudrait votre avis sur l'affaire
Snowden ce jeune j'ai trouvé incroyable
que la France donne pas lu donne pas
l'asile sutaé justice mais là on est
dans la géopolitique on est dans la
réale politique et on est dans voilà on
s'attaque pas impunément aux États-Unis
quoi ces gens font de la politique mais
ils font pas la politique donc ils ont
aucun courage ils ont aucune et ils sont
en train de de de vendre leur âme ils
ont perdu ils sont en train de perdre
perdre toutes les batailles il y a
internet quoi voilà ils peuvent rien
contre internet B pas encore ils peuvent
rien sur internet non mais ils pourront
rien ils peuvent faire toutes les lois
qu'ils veulent je ve dire on les emmerde
quoi ils y arriveront pas
[Musique]
en fait prisme c'est juste un un
sous-programme particulier d'un plan
plus général autre fois ça s'appelait ça
s'inscrit d'ailleurs dans le un
programme que l'on conna
s'appellechelon alors ni les Russes ni
les Chinois n'ont envie que l'ONU se
transforme en une machine à donner les
bons et les mauvais points de
gouvernance et
[Musique]